[Music]
spleen is the largest secondary lymphoid
organ and spleen acts like a blood
filter removing old red blood cells
cream houses lymphocytes and monocytes
there are T cell and B cell zones inside
the spleen
so if we look at the anatomy of the
spleen there are periarterular lymphoid
sheath or pulse which is a T Cell Zone
then there are follicles which are B
cell Zone and the marginal Zone contains
the interaction zone for T cell and the
dendritic cell
so the several anatomy of the spleen
talks about its functionality
the bacterial encounter or any kind of
pathogen encounter happens in the
marginal Zone then in periarteriola
sheet or Pals the T cells get activated
by dendritic cells and the B cells get
activated in the follicle
watch the full video to know more